françoise hardy ça va bien je parle de
tours de chant ce moment puisque depuis
quelques temps c'est votre rentrée oui
enfin bien moi bien très peu de temps
alors on peut pas juger sur les première
fois commencé les premières fois on
était agréable j'espère que ça va
continuer comme c'est important quand
même oui merci
aujourd'hui combien de chansons sur
scène 11 combien ça ne vous en tant
qu'auteur compositeur
je ne sais pas je peux faudrait que je
compte maintenant appris que de prendre
pas mal de temps je peux remettons la
moitié est depuis quelques temps vous
fait appel quand même à des compositeurs
comme par exemple mon amie la rose comme
vge semble toujours fait appel à
d'autres auteurs d'autres compositeurs
préférés
je préfère parce que moi je fais
toujours le même style de chanson alors
ça risquerait de tomber un peu dans la
monotonie si je faisais pas appel
d'autres gens quand vous avez débuté
parce que cette fille sinda pour réussi
en disant voilà je me donne trois ans
car non pas du tout pas du tout mais
toute façon la seule chose que
j'ambitionnais c'était de nos registres
in disque est vraiment joaillier pas
plus loin
moyens pour moi c'était le bout du monde
de pouvoir enregistrer un disque est
maintenant au bout maintenant
je vis au jour le jour j'attends de voir
ce qui va se passer
pas énormément d'ambition total tort
mais et dans la vie quelles sont vos
ambitions là en menant la vie c'est
c'est d'être heureuse et parents trop de
gens malheureux mais vous y arrivez
pour la première chose oui la dose et
oui c'est à dire la deuxième les gens
dont j'aime pas parler de ça aujourd'hui
françoise vous ne recevez pas chez vous
mais ils ont presque dans un studio un
studio de photographe et ce studio
appartient à jean marie périer c'est
cela oui et d'ailleurs je crois que
puisque jean marie est là maintenant il
paraît que vous fait vos débuts en tant
que réalisateur puisque je viens show
qui va se alors pour thème françoise
pour des fêtes de noël je crois que
c'est vous qui l'avez réalisé non un
musée c'est gérard si j'ai fait que
participer à la réalisation
j'ai filmé quelques chansons et
françoise comment est-il comme
réalisateur jean marie périer très bien
très bien on verra où est-ce que ça
s'est passé a été tournée alors c'est
pour ça que c'était dur
c'est à dire parce qu'on avait aucune
permission de tourner il paraît qu'ils
avaient détourné 11 chansons en cinq
jours ce qui n'est pas beaucoup je
prends pas ce qu'on m'a dit vous êtes
photographe de métier
oui et maintenant la réalisation nous
tentons télévision ah oui oui enfin j'ai
envie de faire du cinéma en soins de la
vue les roches de cette émission
oui qu'est ce que ça donne et bien en
france les chansons que jean-marie
assumer entièrement très bien parfait
donc rendez vous en décembre ce moment
là